>>> DOZENS OF MIGRANTS ARE
ARRIVING IN NEW YORK CITY, NOT
BECAUSE IT'S WHERE THEY WANTED
TO GO OR BECAUSE IT'S CLOSE TO
FAMILY.
THIS IS ABOUT POLITICS.
THEY'RE BEING SENT FROM TEXAS
BECAUSE THE GOVERNOR THERE SAYS
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S IMMIGRATION
POLICIES ARE CAUSING A SURGE OF
MIGRANTS ARRIVING IN HIS STATE
OVERWHELMING COMMUNITIES THERE,
SO HE IS SENDING THEM ELSEWHERE,
NAMELY TO DEMOCRAT-LED STATES
AND CITIES.
PAOLO SANDOVAL IS WATCHING
WHAT'S HAPPENING.
NEW YORK'S MAYOR SAYING SOME OF
THESE MIGRANTS ARE NOT HAPPY
WITH COMING HERE, RIGHT?
>> THAT'S THE LATETTE
DEVELOPMENT HERE.
IN APRIL THE TEXAS GOVERNOR
ANNOUNCED PLANS TO BUS MIGRANTS
FROM THE LONE STAR STATE TO
PARTS OF THE NORTHEAST.
WASHINGTON, AND AS OF THIS
FRIDAY, HERE IN NEW YORK CITY.
HE SAID THAT THAT WOULD BE
OFFERED ON A VOLUNTARY BASIS.
ONLY THOSE MIGRANTS THAT HAVE
ALREADY BEEN PROCESSED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
WHO WANT TO BOARD THESE BUSES
FOR A RIDE TO THE NORTHEAST.
HOWEVER, YESTERDAY AND AS RECENT
AS THIS MORNING, NEW YORK CITY
MAYOR ERIC ADAMS SAYS HE'S HAD
AN OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO SOME
OF THOSE RECENT ARRIVALS WHO
CLAIM THAT THEY WERE FORCED TO
BOARD THESE BUSES.
>> SO WHAT HAPPENS NOW?
HOW ARE THEY BEING CARED FOR
HERE?
>> CITIES, WHERE THEY HAVE
FAMILIES, AND THEY JUST PACKED
THEM ON A BUS WITHOUT ANY
DIRECTION.
AND WE LEARNED THAT MANY PEOPLE
HAD TO BE RETICKETED.
THEY WANTED TO GO SOMEWHERE
ELSE, BUT THEY JUST SPECIFICALLY
TARGETED NEW YORK.
THEY BEING THE GOVERNOR OF
TEXAS.
>> AND THIS IS A POTENTIAL
GAME-CHANGER.
SO I REACHED OUT TO TEXAS
GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT'S OFFICE
AND IN THE LAST FEW MINUTES THEY
RESPONDED WITH A STATEMENT.
THESE MIGRANTS WILLINGLY CHOSE
TO GO TO NEW YORK CITY HAVING
SIGNED A VOLUNTARY CONSENT
WAIVER AVAILABLE IN MULTIPLE
LANGUAGES UPON BOARDING, THAT
THEY AGREED ON THE DESTINATION.
SO THAT'S WHAT THE GOVERNOR IS
SAYING, ANA.
WE SAW 14 ARRIVE ON THESE BUSES
YESTERDAY, IN ADDITION TO THE 50
WHICH WAS IN THE FIRST BUS THAT
ARRIVED FROM THE LONE STAR STATE
ON FRIDAY.
>> SO WHAT HAPPENS TO THEM NOW?
HOW IS NEW YORK CARING FOR THEM?
>> THAT'S WHERE IT GETS MORE
COMPLICATED.
FOR THOSE WHO DID NOT INTEND TO
ARRIVE IN NEW YORK CITY OR THIS
IS NOT THEIR FINAL DESTINATION,
THERE IS ASSISTANCE BE GIVEN BY
NEW YORK.
NEW YORK CITY CABS GAVE SOME
RIDES.
YOU ALSO HAVE THOSE WHO MAY
DECIDE TO STAY HERE, AND THAT IS
WHAT MAY FURTHER COMPLICATE THE
SHELTERING SYSTEM IN PLACE HERE
IN NEW YORK CITY.
YOU HAVE AN INCREASE IN
EVICTIONS, YOU HAVE A HOMELESS
CRISIS AS WELL THAT THEY'RE
TRYING TO PLACE PEOPLE, AND NOW
YOU HAVE AS OF LAST MONDAY ABOUT
4,000 ASYLUM SEEKERS WHO HAVE
TURNED TO NEW YORK CITY'S
SHELTERING SYSTEM.
SO THE CITY IS WELCOMING
IMMIGRANTS, HOWEVER, THEY WOULD
LIKE TO SEE MORE COORDINATION
WITH GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT, WHICH
MAY BE REALLY HARD TO GET, AND
AT THE SAME TIME HELP FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE AS WELL.
>> WHAT IS THE GOVERNOR GREG
ABBOTT SAYING?
HE'S SAYING, YES, THEY WANT TO
COME BUT WHAT IS HE SAYING IN
TERMS OF EXPLAINING WHY HE'S
SENDING IMMIGRANTS HERE?
IS THIS REALLY JUST ABOUT TRYING
TO SCORE POLITICAL POINTS OR
MAKING A POLITICAL POINT?
>> IT'S NOT NECESSARILY WHO
WANTS TO BE BROUGHT UP HERE TO
NEW YORK CITY, BUT IT'S WHAT,
AND IN THIS CASE IT CERTAINLY IS
POLITICS.
WHEN YOU HEAR FROM CRITICS OF
THE ABBOTT ADMINISTRATION WHO
SAY THIS IS POLITICAL THEATER, A
STUNT.
MANY OF THESE MIGRANT FAMILIES
HAVE BEEN ALREADY PROCESSED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY AND FREE TO TRAVEL INTO
THE UNITED STATES UNTIL THEY
FINALLY GET THEIR DAY IN COURT
AND ARE BASICALLY GETTING A FREE
RIDE TO CITIES LIKE WASHINGTON
AND LIKE NEW YORK CITY.
HERE'S SOME OF THE GOVERNOR'S
COMMENTS ON FOX NEWS AS HE
EXPLAINS WHY HE SAYS HE'S HAVING
TO DO THIS.
ACTUALLY WE SHOULD MENTION AS WE
MAY WORK TO GET THAT A LITTLE
LATER, HE DOES MAINTAIN IN HIS
PLAN TO HOLD THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION ACCOUNTABLE, IT
IS HIS PLAN TO TAKE THE BORDER
TO PLACES LIKE WASHINGTON, D.C.,
AND NEW YORK CITY AS WELL.
SO THAT'S WHAT HE MAINTAINS IS
THE REASON FOR IT BUT IT IS
CERTAINLY DRAWING SOME CRITICISM
NOT JUST FROM DEMOCRATS BUT
REPUBLICANS AS WELL.
THE TEXAS EMERGENCY OFFICIALS
ARE THE ONES WHO ARE FUNDING
THESE RIDES, SO THESE ARE
TAXPAYER --
>> DOLLARS.
>> -- RIDES FOR THESE MIGRANTS
MAKING THEIR WAY TO NEW YORK
CITY AND AS OF THIS FRIDAY.
>> DELAYS AND CANCELLATIONS
>> I'M JOINED NOW BY THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE NEW
YORK IMMIGRATION COALITION.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US THIS
MORNING.
NOW, THE CITY IS ESTIMATING THAT
SOME 4,000 ASYLUM SEEKERS HAVE
ARRIVED IN THE CITY, GONE INTO
NEW YORK'S SHELTER SYSTEM SINCE
LATE MAY.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THE MAYOR THAT
THESE MIGRANTS ARE BEING FORCED
TO NEW YORK?
>> WELL, THANKS FOR HAVING ME,
ALEX.
PLEASURE TO BE WITH YOU TODAY.
YOU KNOW, ASYLUM SEEKERS HAVE
REALLY ALREADY MADE A DANGEROUS
TREK, SOME OVER 3,000 MILES ON
FOOT TO GET TO THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
AND THEN ARE BEING BUSSED ALMOST
2,000 MILES TO NEW YORK CITY.
I THINK THAT THE BIGGER PIECE
HERE IS ENSURING WE SEE THE
HUMANITY IN PEOPLE.
FOLKS WHO ARE SEEKING ASYLUM AT
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER ARE FLEEING
VIOLENCE.
THEY'RE FLEEING PERSECUTION,
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
NO ONE LEAVES THEIR HOME BECAUSE
THEY FEEL SAFE.
SO, IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
THIS COUNTRY, A COUNTRY OF
IMMIGRANTS, CONTINUES TO WELCOME
FOLKS AND ABIDE BY ITS
HUMANITARIAN, YOU KNOW, VALUES.
>> BUT YOU SAY THEY'RE BEING
BUSSED.
WHO IS DOING THIS?
WHO IS PUSHING THIS?
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT IT IS THE
TEXAS AUTHORITIES WHO ARE
PUTTING THESE MIGRANTS ONTO
THESE BUSES?
DO YOU BELIEVE FEDERAL CUSTOMS
AND BORDER PATROL OFFICERS ARE
DOING THAT?
WHO IS DOING THIS BUSSING?
>> RIGHT NOW, THE LAST TO BUSES
THAT ARCRIVED WERE BUSES FROM TE
STATE OF TEXAS.
GOVERNOR ABBOTT HAS PROUDLY SAID
HE SENT THEM.
I THINK THE BIGGER PIECE HERE IS
FOLKS ARE BEI ING MISLED AT TIM
TO THINK THEY HAVE TO COME TO
NEW YORK CITY.
AND FOLKS SHOULD BE ABLE TO
CHOOSE WHERE THEY WANT TO GO.
A COUPLE WEEKS AGO WE SAW OUR
OFFICE STARTING TO GET INUNDATED
WITH NOTICES TO APPEAR, WHICH
ARE IMMIGRATION COURT HEARING
NOTICES THAT WE DIDN'T KNOW WHO
THESE INDIVIDUALS WERE, BUT THAT
MAIL WAS ADDRESSED TO US.
SO, THERE IS SOME WEIRDNESS
HAPPENING AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER
WHERE PEOPLE ARE BEING ASSIGNED,
GIVEN FAKE ADDRESSES HERE IN NEW
YORK CITY, AS BEEN NOTED IN THE
PAST.
AND IF WE REALLY WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT FOLKS HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SEEK REFUGE IN
THIS COUNTRY, THAT THEY ARE
TREATED AND WELCOMED WITH
DIGNITY AND RESPECT.
>> FROM MY UNDERSTANDING, MANY
OF THESE PEOPLE WHO ARE COMING
BOTH TO NEW YORK AND TO
WASHINGTON, D.C., DON'T HAVE
FRIENDS OR FAMILY IN PLACES IN
THE SOUTH LIKE TEXAS, AS MANY
SAY MIGRANTS FROM MEXICO OR
CENTRAL AMERICA MIGHT.
SO, WHAT ARE YOU HEARING FROM
THE PEOPLE THEMSELVES WHO ARE
MAKING, AS YOU SAY, THIS
INCREDIBLY ARDUOUS JOURNEY UP TO
THE NORTH AND EASTERN PART OF
THE COUNTRY, AFTER ALREADY
HAVING MADE AN INCREDIBLY
DIFFICULT JOURNEY?
>> YOU KNOW, FOLKS ARE REALLY
TRAUMATIZED BY THE JOURNEY THEY
TOOK INITIALLY AND THEN
RETRAUMATIZED AFTER BEING
RELEASED FROM DETENTION BY
PUTTING ON -- BEING PUT ONTO A
BUS FOR 36 TO 48 HOURS, WHERE AT
TIMES THEY'RE NOT ALLOWED OFF
THE BUS, THEY'RE NOT GIVEN FOOD,
AND, YOU KNOW, THE OTHER DAY WE
HAD A YOUNG MAN GET OFF THE BUS
WHO WAS A CHILD.
AND HE, YOU KNOW, DIDN'T FEEL
WELL.
HE DIDN'T RECEIVE CARE IN THE
DETENTION FACILITY AND ACTUALLY
NEEDED INSULIN.
SO, HE WAS TAKEN TO THE
HOSPITAL.
YESTERDAY WE SAW A YOUNG MAN
ALSO GET OFF THE BUS AND WASN'T
FEELING WELL.
SO, FOLKS ARE PUT INTO THESE
HORRIBLE CONDITIONS IN THIS
COUNTRY, WHICH IS MORE THAN
INHUMANE.
AS OPPOSED TO RECEIVING, YOU
KNOW, THE TREATMENT, THEY'RE
JUST BEING SHUTTLED FROM ONE
AREA TO THE NEXT.
AND BEING EXPLOITED BY THE
GOVERNOR OF TEXAS, GOVERNOR
ABBOTT, TO -- AS A POLITICAL
PAWN IN THIS MOMENT.
>> AND THE PROBLEM IS SO ACUTE
THAT THE MAYOR OF WASHINGTON,
D.C., MURIEL BOWSER, HAS TRIED
TO CALL UP THE NATIONAL GUARD TO
HELP WITH THIS ISSUE.
WASHINGTON -- THAT'S ON THE CITY
SIDE.
OF COURSE, THE GOAL OF GOVERNOR
ABBOTT IS TO RAISE THIS ON A
FEDERAL LEVEL.
SO, WHAT MORE ARE YOU HOPING
WILL HAPPEN IN TERMS OF
COORDINATION BETWEEN THOSE
SOUTHERN STATES THAT ARE SENDING
MIGRANTS UP TO WASHINGTON AND TO
NEW YORK?
>> I THINK FIRST AND FOREMOST
WHAT'S MOST IMPORTANT IN THIS
MOMENT IS THEY ACTUALLY TREAT
ASYLUM SEEKERS WHO LAWFULLY ARE
IN THIS COUNTRY WITH THE DIGNITY
THEY DESERVE.
THAT'S THE FIRST THING.
THE SECOND THING IS MAKING SURE
THAT WE ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE CARE
AND THE SERVICES THAT PEOPLE
NEED.
HERE IN NEW YORK CITY, FOLKS WHO
WE ARE RIGHT TO SHELTER STATE,
SO THAT MEANS ANYONE WHO COMES
HERE HAS THE RIGHT TO A SHELTER.
THAT'S ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
PIECES FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
FLEEING VIOLENCE, IS TO HAVE
SOMEWHERE THEY AND THEIR KIDS
CAN LAY THEIR HEADS AT NIGHT.
I THINK RIGHT NOW THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO STEP UP A
LITTLE BIT AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEY ARE RESCINDING POLICIES
THAT ALSO CREATED HORRIFIC
CONDITIONS AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER, LIKE TITLE 42 AND REMAIN
IN MEXICO AND COORDINATE WITH
STATES SO WE'RE ABLE TO MOVE
PEOPLE INTO WHERE THEY WANT TO
GO AND THEN PROVIDE THEM WITH
THE CARE THEY DESERVE.
>> THEY CERTAINLY DESERVE MORE
THAN WHAT THEY'RE GETTING RIGHT
NOW.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
APPRECIATE IT.